Humans have evolved such that we can learn language easily from our verbal
communities, and it is easy to overlook the revolutionary effect that human
language has had in our evolution and development as a species, as well as our
ability to communicate and pass on knowledge from generation to generation.
There is a regular sequence in which we acquire language Beginning with cooing,
then babbling, one-word utterances, and finally, by age three we speak in
grammatical sentences. The case study of Genie demonstrates that there are
critical periods for acquiring language. And after that window of opportunity,
language acquisition is very difficult. We also discussed an important
principle of science and that not all scientists always agree an explanations
and theories. In particular we saw how Skinner and Chomsky had different
explanations for language, a behaviorist view or a nativist view. We covered
the psychology of thought in cognition. And discussed how we represent ideas
both visually and verbally, and use concepts, categories and hierarchies to
organize our thoughts, and to understand our world. We discussed different
kinds of reasoning, deductive and inductive, and how critical thinking can make
us better consumers of information and ideas. Finally, we demonstrated how we
use mental shortcuts, or heuristics, in making decisions, and how those can
help, but sometimes bias our decision-making.